failed former president Donald Trump
delivered a lie riddled all capital
letters endorsement of sorts of Kevin
McCarthy for speaker of the house now
before we look at Trump's post to truth
social truth
I should tell you kind of the back story
of what was going on
um Kevin McCarthy yesterday failed as I
told you in three votes to secure the
218 votes he needs to become the Speaker
of the House embarrassing humiliating
actually losing support as the votes
went on yesterday Donald Trump told NBC
News
or rather didn't tell NBC news whether
he still supported Kevin McCarthy but
Trump took a little bit of time I guess
to think about it or more likely to be
told what it is that he should say and
this morning he did come out with a
three-post tirade on Troth Central where
again we're interpreting Trump's bizarre
language and syntax I guess he's saying
he supports Kevin McCarthy Trump posting
quote some really good conversations
took place last night I think that means
someone told him what to do but okay
some really good conversations took
place last night and it's now time for
all of our great Republican house
members and here he goes caps lock to
vote for Kevin close the deal take the
victory
and watch crazy Nancy Pelosi fly back
home to a very broken California the
only speaker in U.S history to have lost
the house twice Republicans do not turn
a great Triumph into a giant
embarrassing defeat it's time to
celebrate you deserve it Kevin McCarthy
will do a good job maybe even a great
job just watch now it's important to
mention this has nothing to do with
Nancy Pelosi Trump is obsessed with
Pelosi Pelosi said she is stepping down
from leadership
Democrats don't control the house she's
not asking to be minority leader this
has nothing to do with Pelosi but Trump
is obsessed with Pelosi and by the way
it's funny he says McCarthy will do a
good job maybe it'll even be great I
don't know not exactly a ringing
endorsement Trump then adding also on
Truth Central quote if Republicans are
going to fight
we ought to be fighting Mitch McConnell
and his domineering china-loving boss I
mean wife Coco Chao Trump continuing
with the racial epithets or as some
wrongly call them epitaphs which is a
completely different thing the harm they
have done to the Republican party is
incalculable today he couldn't be
elected dog catcher in Kentucky sadly he
only won because of my endorsement went
up 21 points sorry and then lastly Trump
going back to caps lock take the Victory
and run says Donald Trump trump waited
to decide does he stick with Kevin
McCarthy or not apparently he decided
yes he sticks with him but Falling a
little bit short of a full-throated
ringing endorsement we saw others last
night
seemingly taking baby steps away from
Kevin McCarthy this includes
propaganda stuck or Carlson this
includes propaganda Sean Hannity and
others that we will get to after this
short break remember next Wednesday
January 11th 6 PM Eastern 3 P.M Pacific
we will be doing the first viewer Town
Hall of 2023. I hope that you will join
us live everyone is invited to call in
our members will get Priority Access to
talk to me you can sign up at
joinpakman.com and remember always
remember
subscribe to the YouTube channel folks
three million of you watched our Clips
last month and did not subscribe hit
that subscribe button help us get to 2
million did you know that half of
Americans are deficient in vitamin A
vitamin C and magnesium most Americans
are deficient in vitamin D I take
vitamin D during the winter it is
sometimes difficult to eat exactly the
right amount of each food to get exactly
what you need I just make my life
simpler with ag1 by athletic Greens in
the morning one scoop of ag1 I get the
entire day's worth of 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and Whole Food sourced
ingredients it's what I want it's no
more it's no less it's not making any
outlandish claims it's just an easy
sustainable routine I've tried different
ways of taking vitamins ag1 is cheaper
it's quicker it's tastier I'm not
fumbling around with different capsules
it tastes great to drink straight with
water sometimes I'll put it in a
smoothie or Shake it's simple it's
something easy you can do going into the
new year staying properly nourished
athletic greens is giving my audience a
free year supply of vitamin D I take
that every day in Winter plus you'll get
five free travel packs of ag1 go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman the link is
down below